you
honest it miss going on center that
Caitlyn Jenner is a fan of the show yes
I met I met Caitlyn and she told me that
today that you know that she watched the
show and yet she is a fan and I have her
and what an interesting world it is you
know there's this fictive show that we
have in there's her show and there's
this wonderful revolution that's going
on in the world great any chance that
she might make a cameo on the show
someday I don't know but it will she'll
always be in Maura's head but you can
come to craft service anytime and I'll
walk her around and give her finger
sandwiches I don't think so I don't
think I don't think that's how it works
out you know there you have it I mean
it's it's done have you talked to her
about this show I mean other than I know
you've had little brief conversations
but i actually had dinner with her one
night with a group of people and we just
talked and chatted and angie was very
very inspirational to us and then there
are a lot of people in the transgender
community who don't have that power who
don't have that money and don't have the
proper wig yet and everything that so
I'm rooting for everybody